DOWN OPPORTUNISTS?
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
ALL RIGHT, HOWEVER HE RECEIVED
THE PRESIDENT'S ADDRESS TONIGHT,
ONE THING SHOULD NOT BE
MISSED.
THE PRESIDENT SCORED A MAJOR
MEDIA COUP.
WHAT AM I TALKING ABOUT?
HE GOT ALL THE MAJOR NETWORKS TO
CARRY HIS ADDRESS, GALVANIZING
THE ATTENTION OF THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY, AND HE ACCOMPLISHED
SOMETHING ELSE.
HE GOT TWO OF THE LEAST POPULAR
POLITICIANS IN THE NATION TO
RESPOND TO HIM ON HIS TERMS.
>> HE WANTS TO RAISE THE STAKES
AND MAKE THE DEMOCRATS OF THE
CO-OWNERS OF THOSE SHUT DOWN AND
I THINK NANCY PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER ARE WALKING RIGHT
INTO THE TRAP.
HE BRINGS EVERYONE AN END THIS
IS THE TRAP.
THAT IS NOT A WAY TO GET TO
RATIONAL ENDING.
>> Laura: OKAY, BUT THIS IS
RATIONAL?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS REJECTING
THESE BIPARTISAN BILLS WHICH
WOULD REOPEN GOVERNMENT OVER
FORCING AMERICAN TAXPAYERS TO
WASTE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON AN
EXPENSIVE AND INEFFECTIVE WALL.
>> WE ARE NOT GOVERNED BY TEMPER
TANTRUMS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SUCCUMBED TO
FEAR, NOT FACTS.
A DIVISION, NOT UNITY.
THERE IS AN OBVIOUS SOLUTION:
SEPARATE THE SHUTDOWN FROM
ARGUMENTS OVER BORDER SECURITY.
>> Laura: OKAY, NOW, THE
CONTRAST SHOULD BE GLARING FOR
ANYONE WHO WATCHED TONIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS REALLY SOBER
TONIGHT, HE WAS REALLY SERIOUS.
HE GENUINELY BELIEVES THAT A
WALL IS NEEDED AS PART OF A
LARGER BORDER SECURITY POLICY.
THAT IS WHAT HE WON THE CAMPAIGN
ON.
DEMOCRATS DO NOT GIVE A DAMN
ABOUT SECURING THE BORDER.
FOR THEM, IT IS ALL ABOUT
SECURING CLINICAL POINTS AND OF
COURSE ABOUT 2020.
>> WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN WILLING
TO TALK TO THE PRESIDENT ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY, AND MANY OF US
HAVE SUPPORTED SOME PRETTY
MASSIVE INVESTMENTS IN BORDER
SECURITY IN THE PAST.
BUT WE CAN'T DO THAT WHILE THE
GOVERNMENT'S SHUTDOWN.
WE NEED TO OPEN UP GOVERNMENT
AND THEN NEGOTIATE, NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND.
>> WE BELIEVE IN SECURE BORDERS
BUT WE WANT THE GOVERNMENT OPEN.
>> ONCE THE GOVERNMENT IS OPEN I
WOULD SUPPORT LOOKING AT A
BROADER COMPROMISE ON
IMMIGRATION.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, DON'T
BELIEVE ANYTHING THEY ARE
TELLING YOU THERE, NOT EVEN FOR
A MILLISECOND.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TARGETING THE
800,000 GOVERNMENT WORKERS ON
FURLOUGH, THEY ARE TARGETING
THEM.
WHAT DO I MEAN?
THEY REFUSED TO MOVE TOWARDS A
COMMON SENSE COMPROMISE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
REMEMBER, A YEAR AGO THEY WERE
WILLING TO GIVE HIM A
$25 BILLION FOR A WALL, BUT
SCHUMER ULTIMATELY PULLED THAT
OFF THE TABLE.
BUT THEY WERE WILLING TO DO
THAT.
NOW TODAY THEY CAN'T EVEN COME
UP WITH A MEASLY $5 BILLION
QUESTION MIGHT THINK OF ALL THE
WASTE, FRAUD, AND ABUSE IN THIS
TOWN THAT THEY COULD TRIM A WAY
TO GET THAT $5 BILLION.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT IN A
BIT.
THE PRESIDENT HASN'T SHOWN A
WILLINGNESS TO COMPROMISE, YOU
HEARD IT TONIGHT.
FUNDING REQUEST THIS WEEK,
THE PRESIDENT ASKED FOR ITEMS
THAT ARE ALSO IMPORTANT TO
DEMOCRATS, HE ALLUDED TO THIS
TONIGHT.
OF COURSE, $800 MILLION FOR
HUMANITARIAN AID AT THE BORDER,
AND THAT INCLUDES MEDICAL
SUPPORT AND ADDITIONAL
FACILITIES TO HOUSE MIGRANTS,
WHICH FRANKLY A LOT OF AMERICANS
WOULD THINK BETTER SPENT ON
INNER-CITY YOUTH AND VETERANS,
BUT NEVERTHELESS THE PRESIDENT
IS WILLING TO GO THERE.
OF THE PRESIDENT IS ALSO
REQUESTING $605 MILLION FOR NEW
TECHNOLOGY TO DETECT AND STOP
THE FLOW OF ILLEGAL DRUGS OVER
THE BORDER.
IT DEMOCRATS HAVE LONG SAID THEY
WANTED THAT!
BUT DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO HAVE
AN HONEST CONVERSATION ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY.
THEY ARE NOW THE PARTY OF
OBSTRUCTION, AND EVERYTHING MUST
BEND TO THEIR RESIST-TRUMP
GOALS.
"THE HILL" REPORTS OF THEIR
LATEST STRATEGY IS TO JAM UP OF
THE SENATE BY REFUSING TO
CONSIDER ANY LEGISLATION UNTIL
THE GOVERNMENT IS REOPENED.
>> THIS CANNOT BE BUSINESS AS
USUAL.
WE HAVE SHUT DOWN A QUARTER OF
THE GOVERNMENT AND JUST LEAVE IT
SHUT DOWN.
IT'S AN INCOMPETENT STRATEGY.
>> Laura: JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF HOW DOGMATIC AND RABID
AND HOW FANATICAL THIS
RESISTANCE TO TRUMP HAS BECOME,
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN THE
DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED AGAINST
CONSIDERING A BILL TO SUPPORT
ISRAEL EARLIER TODAY.
WHAT?
SO, WE ARE NOT GOING TO SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE BOYCOTTS AGAINST
ISRAEL BECAUSE TRUMP WANTS TO DO
A DEAL ON THE BORDER WALL?
HOW IS THAT GOVERNING IN A
MATURE WAY?
I'M SURE THE NEW ANTI-SEMITIC
WING OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS
THRILLED ABOUT THIS DEVELOPMENT
IN THE SENATE, BUT MOST
AMERICANS ARE NOT.
AGAIN, DON'T FOCUS ON WHAT THEY
SAY.
IT SOUNDS FINE AND REASONABLE.
WATCH WHAT THEY DO.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT THE SHUTDOWN
TO GO ON AS LONG AS POSSIBLE TO
DIVIDE AS MANY REPUBLICANS FROM
THE PRESIDENT AS THEY CAN.
THEY WANT TO PEEL ONE OFF AFTER
ANOTHER AND THEN THEY WANT TO
RAMP IT UP FOR POLITICAL
PRESSURE.
OUR SAFETY AND SECURITY, FORGET
THAT.
IF THEY WANTED THE GOVERNMENT
REOPENED, THE DEMOCRATS COULD
NEGOTIATE WITH THE GOVERNMENT
AND REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT
TOMORROW.
HE HAS ALREADY COMPROMISED ON
THE STRUCTURE OF THE WALL, AND
HE DROPPED HIS ASKING PRICE AS
WE KNOW IT WAY DOWN AND WHILE
THE DEMOCRATS FEIGN CONCERN OVER
SPENDING A FEW BILLION DOLLARS
ON THE PORTABLE, $5.7 BILLION,
THE COASTAL WONDER TWINS OF
THEIR PARTY, GOVERNOR NEWSOM OF
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK HAVE ALL
KINDS OF MONEY.
THEY HAVE POTS OF MONEY FOR THE
HEALTH CARE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> WE WILL NEVER WAVER IN OUR
PURSUIT OF GUARANTEED
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
>> HEALTH CARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
IN THIS CITY, WE ARE GOING TO
MAKE THAT A REALITY.
IN THE CITY, WE ARE TAKING THAT
IDEAL AND PUTTING IT INTO
PRACTICE.
FROM THIS MOMENT ON A
NEW YORK CITY, EVERYONE IS
GUARANTEED THE RIGHT TO
HEALTH CARE.
>> Laura: WELL, THEY HAVE NO
PROBLEM FINDING ALL THAT MONEY
FALLING FROM THE SKY TO SPEND ON
THE WELL-BEING AND HEALTH OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
MY FRIENDS, LIKE EVERYTHING
ELSE, THIS IS ALL ABOUT POLITICS
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
PRETTY MUCH EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUP IN THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW
IS BETTER OFF THAN THEY WERE
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER TO THAT.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO
GO OUT AND ARGUE, OKAY, WE WILL
OFFER THESE THREE POLICIES AND
RAISE YOUR STANDARD OF LIVING TO
A HIGHER LEVEL THAN PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO.
NO, THEY GAVE UP ON THAT.
ALL THEY HAVE TO RUN ON IS THIS
SHUT DOWN AND THEIR OPPOSITION
TO THE WALL.
OH, SORRY, AND TRUMP IS A
RACIST.
THAT'S ALL THEY HAVE.
FOR AN ADDED BONUS, THEY
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
STALEMATE FOR THE SHUTDOWN
FURNISHES THEM WITH ANOTHER
POLITICAL WEAPON TWO, GUESS
WHAT?
FURTHER THE REAL NIRVANA FOR
AMERICANS THAT THIS IS REALLY
GOING TO HELP YOUR LIFE GET
BETTER, THE IMPEACHMENT AGENDA.
YEAH, TO TRUMP'S THREAT TO
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY,
WHICH NEVER HAPPENED, IN
BUILDING THE WALL ITSELF COULD
HASTEN THE DEMOCRATS' ULTIMATE
DESIRED END. END.
>> THIS KIND OF ABUSE OF POWER
MAY ALSO OPEN UP OTHER MEASURES
FOR CONGRESS, BECAUSE THIS IN
FACT COULD HIT THE TRIPWIRE OF
ABUSE OF POWER, WHICH IS ALSO
ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT COULD
LEAD TO A PRESIDENTIAL
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
I HEARD THAT THIS MORNING, I WAS
LIKE, WOW, YOU ARE REALLY
SPITTING IT OUT.
WHILE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
STRAINING TO SQUEEZE THE LAST
BIT OF POLITICAL JUICE FROM THE
SHUTDOWN, THE PRESIDENT IS DOING
THE RIGHT THING.
HE IS FOCUSED ON THE SECURITY
AND THE SOVEREIGNTY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND THEIR PROSPERITY.
THAT'S GOOD POLICY, BUT IN TIME